infinite
eternal modulations
how many different combinations of music
can you think of how many different
combinations of
art can you think of think about a
painting and think about
colors how many different color
combinations in different places on a
painting can you think of
how many different ways to sculpt out
a slab of marble into a sculpture
can you think of
how many different combinations of
energy can you think of
the closer you get to endless the closer
you get to
infinite as your answer to these
the more you are honed in on the true
nature of our reality
it's that simple symphonies
don't play one song we're not here
for one song for one verse for universe
we are here for multiverse eternally
playing
many songs
we've been doing it we're gonna keep
doing it this is just
one expression this is one modulation of
music
this is one modulation of art this is
one
modulation of energy which even quantum
mechanics
is proving that everything is
modulations of energy which appear as
form which appear as matter
this is one song out of infinite songs
that we are playing
how many combinations
of a plant cell expressing itself can
you think of
how many combinations of a stem cell
expressing itself
can you think of how many combination of
zygotes
expressing themselves can you think of
how many combinations of
big bangs expressing themselves can you
think of
so how many different plants
are even just here on this planet earth
on this dreamed creation design
how many are just here millions
of different combinations of plant cells
expressing themselves
how many animals millions of species of
animals
how many humans are there
billions of expressions of humans
and that's what the iris is the iris
around the pupil is the unique
coloration it's the unique
expression of infinity and the pupil is
what we share that's the shared
awareness
that's the god realization
how many civilizations can you
imagine if the answer is
endless then you're honing in on the
nature of reality
it's as simple as that
how many musical notes do you know how
to play in an octave
are you just playing the c
maybe you also know d
or do you know all eight
c d e f g a b
do you know all
red orange yellow green
blue indigo violet do you know all of
the colors
on the palette on the rainbow
do you know a whole octave do you know a
whole
suite of colors on the rainbow
or do you only know red do you only know
red and green
do you only know those two how many
color combinations of the rainbow how
many color combinations of musical notes
how many color combinations of energetic
expressions of the formless appearing as
form and matter can you imagine
how many civilizations on rocks
orbiting stars can you imagine
can you go back and imagine the other
dreamed creation designs that we were
experiencing
can you imagine in the future the other
dream creation designs that we'll be
experiencing can you recognize that this
is just one song
that the symphony is playing
also in computer science you can think
about this as the infinite modulations
of binary
here you see the b is
in binary zero one zero zero
zero zero one zero that is b capital b
and so binary
is the six capital characters there
which are its own unique string of zeros
and ones
how many different modulations of binary
can you think of the answer is infinite
it's endless and that's how computation
works that's how it also represents
itself on the user interface
to you while you use the device and it's
very similar with
rgb modulations for pixels
look at all of these pixels that are
appearing on your device right now
those are all modulations of red green
and blue rgb
and so it's a very specific amount of
red it's a specific amount of green it's
a specific amount of blue that forms the
exact color of that exact pixel
and then the pixel that's next to it as
in the microphone pixel is going to be
different than the pixel of my eye which
is different than the pixel of my
shirt
that's what this is infinite eternal
modulations
of pixels infinite eternal modulations
of binary
infinite eternal modulations of plant
cells of animal cells of
zygotes of big bangs of musical
performance
of artistic expression of
fluctuations of energy
time is simply made up symbols it's
fantastic
that we did it because it's really
useful
this is extremely useful over the last
millennia since we've invented these
little
squiggly lines on a clock to represent
the rotation of planet earth on
its axis it's been fantastic because we
get to say hey
meet me at 1pm at this location
and we figured out how to be able to do
that efficiently
instead of having to look up at the sun
and use sundials so this is actually
pretty good
but it's completely illusory it's not
what it appears to be
this is not a objective representation
of eternity
this is the simple symbological
representation that we've ascribed
to finity we've ascribed
to this form to this
appearance to this reality we've
ascribed these squiggly lines to
represent the rotation of the earth on
its axis
once you wake up to that you are really
becoming
awakened to eternity to infinity because
this
is useful but it's a cultural
dogmatic hypnosis when you believe that
this
is ultimate reality because this is not
ultimate reality this is just one
expression of reality this is
one color combination one musical
combination
because you can take this clock and you
can begin changing these squiggly lines
and maybe you only want four squiggly
lines
over here and maybe they're going to be
different squiggly lines
and maybe they're going to have
different increments instead of having
60 seconds in a minute
maybe there's only 10 of these
incremental units
in each incremental minute you can tell
that the minute the hour the second the
day
the week the year these are all
useful to describe the rotation of the
earth on its axis and the
orbit of the earth around the star
they're fantastic
and they've been great but you can tell
that they're all absolutely made
up symbols the months of the year made
up
words made up symbols
again it's fantastic but we have to know
the truth the eternal infinite truth
that those are made up symbols
they're useful but they're made up
symbols if you're talking to your friend
or your family or co-worker or somebody
online ask them if they know that time
is an illusion
if you have that conversation with more
people about time
simply being made up symbols you will
slowly awaken people to eternity and
infinity at a faster rate
quantum mechanics all is energy slash no
thing it's become so clear in the last
hundred years
and thank goodness that physics got to
this point
because it is not all just form and
matter
the underlying structure is a bunch of
energy modulations and fluctuations that
then give the appearance of
matter they give the appearance of form
and now we're here and now we see the
statistical probabilities of the waves
and we're like oh [ __ ] now all of the
spiritual wisdom
around the formless makes sense
sciences as donald hoffman said in our
interview
is johnny come lately to the spiritual
party
the spiritual party for thousands of
years has been exploring the formless
it's been
exploring consciousness exploring
awareness exploring eternity and
infinity
and science is coming around in the last
couple of hundred years and especially
these last couple of decades
and finally it's like hey look if sir
roger penrose
who won the nobel prize in physics in
2020 has a theory of cyclic cosmology
then maybe physics should take the
oroboros in eternity and infinity
seriously
yes no [ __ ] we don't just live in one
song
one finite expression that would make no
sense
zero sense it only makes sense to
shatter
both sides of that finite expression to
the infinite
and recognize this is just one
expression
similarly language is communication
vibrations
all that is happening here is my vocal
cords are vibrating and sending you
a signal of language of communication of
meaning that you're interpreting
in your process of god realization and
god actualization
of the inward and the outward that's the
only reason why people are tuning into
this channel
is because we are tuned into metaphysics
we're tuned into the nature of reality
we're tuned into consciousness to
awareness to the synthesis of science
and spirituality
like nobody else is and we're
disseminating it
very artistically and very synthetically
across
disciplines in ways that resonate with
people and that's why you're tuned into
these communication vibrations
and that's simply what it is because if
you think about vocal vibrations
they produce infinite languages right
now there are seven thousand or so
languages across the planet and like way
davis said in our interview on our show
that within just a couple of decades
that number is going to be halved to 3
500 languages it's called
ethnographic condensation so the
languages are condensing down
into just the main english mandarin
arabic
spanish etc and
that's the idea behind you can create an
infinite amount of
languages
and so you can have these different
vibratory
communications that occur in languages
across
english russian spanish or a completely
made up language
and so you can sort of begin making
things up
languish wise and vibration wise
as well and people are doing that right
now they're trying to optimize language
by creating new languages and whatnot as
well and we're entering into the whole
neuralink and artificial general
intelligence
era where we'll be able to become more
telepathic with one another as well
which is fascinating
but you have to recognize there's
there's an infinite amount of meaning
that can also be communicated with these
vocal vibrations
so if you begin to understand that the
vocal
vibrations are very similar to the
nature of reality
as in the same way we can communicate
infinite meaning and infinite language
with vocal vibration is the same way
that the
of the ineffable of the absolute
can modulate the appearances
of all of these dreamed creations
it's so critical to draw these analogies
it's so critical to think from first
principles of the
infinite rather than the contracted
energy of the finite
you go to the infinite first you go to
the god realization first which then
makes an
effortless action a wu way of channeling
the absolute
highest morality as you go into the god
actualization into the unique artistic
expression
your iris the unique coloration
of you as an expression of infinity
infinity being the pupil
expressing itself as the iris
if you're trying to express yourself
from just the finite
contracted energy you're going to hit
your head
and toes against everything
and constantly be hitting breaking
points seeking happiness and peace
externally which can't be found
the diamond necklace is around your neck
that's why in the parable of the
prodigal son
it's the turn inward towards awareness
and consciousness
the diamond necklace around the neck
already
and it's fascinating because it's
literally the same
awareness that
takes on expressions
in the dream and then it talks to itself
so we are the same awareness we're
taking on these unique
expressions we're the same infiniti the
same ineffable absolute taking on these
expressions
within this dreamed creation of our own
and we're talking to ourselves
if you've gotten to that level of
realization
in metaphysics you win you win the game
you got it and then the sahaja samadhi
as ramana maharshi said the tantric path
the middle path as buddha said is where
you weave
your profound enlightenment realizations
into the social fabric so you become
the architect of the sustainable
development goals of maximizing human
potential
of making the pie bigger and more
abundant for everybody
to actualize their unique gifts and god
realize
and that's why queen in bohemian
rhapsody which is one of my favorite
songs of all time and it's crazy
i can go back to middle school when we
were listening to this
song on the bus on the way to school
and back from school and we were sharing
the little head
the earbuds one in my ear and one in my
friend's ear like with
max chadliev and so many of my other
friends
and we would be sitting there and
listening to
the some of the first ipods
that were made by apple and we were
uploading
our songs onto them in bohemian
rhapsodies one of them
and in middle school you would never
think while you're listening to the
lyrics
that you would
almost 20 years later
15 20 years later that you'd be
listening to this music
and it would make more sense to you and
i love that
about life i love it when i watch a
movie
and then five years later i watch it
again and i'm like holy [ __ ] i didn't
see all of that detail all that more
nuance the exegesis i'm drawing out more
salience now from it similar with books
similar with music similar with art
if you go and view the sistine chapel
when you're 15 years old and then you go
back and you view it again when you're
30
you're going to see a lot more you've
become wiser you're going to be able to
draw out more salience
and so in queen's bohemian rhapsody when
they sing
nothing really matters
anyone can see
nothing really matters
nothing really matters to
me dun dun dun dun dun
[Music]
the wind blows
that is profound because
it has a lot to do with non-duality it
has a lot to do with the
anarchic creative expression that is the
ineffable the absolute
in the most ultimate truth sense nothing
really matters
it's all just perfect and
unconditionally free and whole and just
expressing itself and this is beautiful
and we are that
and then in the dualistic concession you
say there's suffering and there's
well-being and we want to architect
towards well-being there's ignorance
of our metaphysical nature and there's
enlightenment of our metaphysical nature
and we want to
help people go up that mountain to the
one end
and then very similarly in the non-dual
tradition is the
any way the wind blows as
is said in the law of one as well why
are you trying to
capture the wind and put it into a book
think about that just be the wind
be the infinite and in my
expression in this atlas expression i
am the wind which is also trying to
capture the wind and put it into the art
because it's the coolest thing for this
expression to do
in many ways the coolest thing you can
do is recognize the ineffable and how
it's absolutely indescribable
and then the second coolest thing you
can do is to try and express that in art
and help be awakening for other people
and it's exciting and it's
infinite eternal modulations that are
happening
as combinations of music combinations of
art combinations of energy
the infinite combinations of plants of
animals of humans of civilizations
of binary of rgb
all of the different ways that
the illusion of time can be expressed
all of the different ways we can use
these vibrations to communicate
language and meaning
we are the same awareness taking on
unique expressions in a dream and
talking to itself
that's it infinite eternal modulations
really hone in on this hone in on the
endless combinations of energy the
endless combinations of art
the endless combinations of music
because that's what this
is this is but one
expression of music this is one song
this is one sculpture this is one
artistic painting
one modulation at the energetic level
dreamed creation design this is finite
it's a contraction it's beautiful but we
are eternal we are beyond this one
we are all of it that's been happening
and it's going to keep happening
recognize that awaken to that and that's
enlightenment and share that with other
people
become aware of awareness become aware
that we share our being become
aware that we are eternal and we are
being colored
by these creation designs colored by
experience
we are the sky experiencing the clouds
we are the ocean experiencing the waves
we are the screen experiencing the
modulations
when you get to the infinite eternal
modulations level
you got it i adore you
infinite love thank you for tuning in if
the video brought you value like the
video subscribe if you haven't
leave me a comment below would love to
hear from you
and also share the video with people
that you know it would profoundly
impact if you'd like join the channel
memberships
we have great exclusive benefits and
every single dollar that comes in we
fund to the actual legit
actualization of all of our major
projects
and
that's all just again
how many of combinations
of music of art of energy
endless infinite this
is but one
you